foreign
[Music]
T immortality it's about using GitHub to
make your work live forever you can
follow me on Twitter at underscore tanho
slides are this is actually a GitHub
repository but the slides are uploaded
to that
um okay so I'd like to start
bye wait a second
Target
clicker yes we like clickers okay so
let's introduce you to The Life and
Times of a data science project okay
um this might sound familiar to most of
you certainly the story of most of my
projects if not all of them
you start by importing some data okay
whether that's from from scraping apis a
database pre-existing data stuff that
your company has whatever it is okay you
start by importing some data then you
get to know this data you do some
wrangling you do some feature
engineering you start doing some
exploratory data analysis try to
understand how messy the data is and how
bad your data is shout out to Jim
um and then once you've kind of done
with that and you kind of understand
that data a little bit as from a human
perspective you start trying to teach
your computer to do something with it so
you throw into a model you try to get
some clustering done or regressions or
try to predict a number
and then you study the results of that
output
you plot it and then you tweet the plot
okay so you know you share it with the
world you've learned something here's
what here's what I've learned here's you
know get some feedback on it validation
it's 15 minutes of fame hopefully
um hopefully Everyone likes it you get
some feedback and then
most projects die here right
and it's it's rightfully so because
you've learned something you've you've
done what you set out to do you've
learned something from that project and
you're ready to move on
sometime later this happens
relevant XKCD as ever never have I ever
felt so close to another soul and yet so
helplessly alone as when I googled this
problem and there's one result a thread
by someone who studied the exact same
problem that I'm interested in and it
was last posted to in 2020. 2020 feels
like 20 2003 right
who were you Denver code 09 who were you
tan what did you see what did you learn
story happens a lot right and you
whether it's a stack Overflow answer a
problem a GitHub sometimes now you'll
Google and you'll find a Twitter thread
how do you help this person actually I'm
not that interested in how you help that
person because the answer is they'll
reach out to you if you're available
you'll spend time and energy and you'll
give them give it back to them if you
have time right what I'm actually more
interested in is how can your project
help this person because at the end of
the day that's not always possible
whether you're constrained when you your
time has limits your energy has limits
your project should be able to help them
and get what they need from it and move
on so Mike Mike my question my talk
today is going to be about how can you
help your project help this person and I
think that there's
skipped a slide on me that GitHub has a
bunch of resources that can really help
you along this path
so who this talk is for
this talk is for people who are doing
personal hobby projects it's for people
who are doing academic research it's for
people who are interested in public and
open source work more broadly
it's for people who don't have a budget
when they're doing their work and the
people who are interested in helping
others use their work and helping their
project live on
so why do I care so much about this this
is me this is literally my profile
picture on every single Twitter and
twitch and everything else about me
um in a past life I was a property
manager grew up in the family business
absolutely hated that job okay so along
this on the side I started doing fantasy
football started analyzing it started
um
teaching myself some data analysis to go
with it started with Excel power query
eventually learned R taught myself
basically football analysis NFL fantasy
football Etc eventually that led to a
data science career
um I got a job as in a Home Building
Company doing data science and doing
programming and eventually and recently
I've just accepted a position with
zealous analytics to work on pro soccer
so you know you can turn you can't you
can make that career switch if you're
interested by doing this sort of thing
and then today along the way I've become
a maintainer of public NFL data and I
maintain NFL verse and FF verse art
packages for NFL and fantasy football
respectively
so why do I care so much about this I've
been the hobbyist programmer I've been
the person who's broke and looking for
it look want you to do stuff without a
budget and I care today even still about
making sure that people can build on my
work and can use my work in their own
projects
so let's talk about one of my projects
FF opportunity so it's a project that
uses NFL play-by-play data to study
expected fantasy points now I'm not
going to go into the details about NFL
or or expect your trans points you don't
need to know anything about that but if
you're interested expected fantasy
points help measure the value of play
opportunities in fantasy football and
you can find my project here github.com
FF first FF opportunity
I'll take you to the structure anyway
though so this might sound familiar you
start by importing some manifold versus
play-by-play data
then I wrangled some features together
trained an XG boost model
and then used it use that model to
predict fantasy points right this is the
story of every machine learning project
every data science project really now
what
how can I make FF opportunity live on
I'm actually going to frame this
question how what what is this person
who stumbles on my project later
interested in and what kind of questions
are they going to be asking
how can they use and improve on my model
no model is perfect
but they're useful and then
understanding how past work has
understanding the password in that field
can help you improve on that model where
does where the gaps are understand how
to use it understand how to improve it
where the you know that kind of thing
can new predictions be automated every
week maybe they're good with this model
but they're interested in how the
prediction what the predictions are and
what the model says about games that
haven't happened yet and games that are
going to happen soon so can you automate
new predictions every week of the NFL
season there's there's new slate of
games every week from September through
till January February
lastly where can they find these
predictions where can I put it where can
they access the predictions in a way
that's not trying to you know ask me to
email them or tweet them or send them
these predictions it's no good if it
lives in my computer right so let's go
through these questions one by one can
someone use and improve on my model
there's a lot of work in the r space now
in terms of reproducibility rnv is a
great option Docker is a great option
the one I actually like to use is making
it a package and I'm not talking about
making it for cran but I think there's
two elements of packages that I think
are really underrated and help kind of
build things going forward one of them
is adding a description file and the
other one's wrapping code into functions
adding a description file
one of the things that adding a
description file does it forces you or
asks you to add a license and a license
is really important especially when
you're doing public work because it
tells people what you're okay with them
doing with your work right so if you
want them to if you're okay with doing
if them doing anything with that say so
add an MIT license that's what that's
basically there for if you want them to
only use this work to help extend public
work you can use a license like GPL V3
right so just choosing the license helps
communicate that you want them to use
that work and by sharing that work to
them with that license people can
understand what you what you're okay
with them doing with it
the other thing that it does is it makes
dependencies it makes the installation
of dependencies really easy because
you're forced to list all the
dependencies and if you're able to also
list the minimum versions
um it makes things like remotes or pack
or Pac-Man work because they can read
the description file from GitHub and
then install all the dependencies for
you while you're installing this package
for this package and even if it doesn't
have any functions in it it'll still
install the dependencies for you and
then you can use that in you know
running the script after you've cloned
it on GitHub
of course useless has this covered so
you don't actually need to type out a
description file it's got four functions
that you need to know to do exactly what
I'm talking about use description use
MIT license use package for each package
that you're using then once you've added
all the packages you use use latest
dependencies and it's going to version
lock the version that's on your machine
so it'll put on you'll put that in as
the minimum version and then you know
you've got there you go you set this up
to for success
the other thing that I like to do this
kind of the next level is to wrap logic
into functions
um it's really easy for users so from
your end of things what you need to do
is convert the hard-coded variables and
data frames to arguments extract
function is a cool feature in our studio
Control Alt X and then if you
copy and paste or if you select the
entire code chunk and you press this
shortcut I think it's command option X I
don't use a Mac but it's related
um it'll automatic automatically create
a function and put the skeleton of your
code in a function and take all the
variables and put them into arguments so
this already basically does it for you
and then the other thing you can do is
add some usage notes I'm going to say
documentation here because documentation
scares people but really understanding
how you use logic how you use the
function and what the function is meant
to do will help other people kind of
understand where you're going with it
and the goal is to make it easy for
users to run right so our users love
functions they understand exactly what
to do when you give them a function you
put arguments into it and then you kind
of go from there
okay so we talked about packages that's
all that's that's the bare minimum
there's a whole bunch more in packages
there's a whole book on it
um
but from my end of things that's the
bare minimum
the next thing I'm going to talk about
is how can you predict new uh automatic
can you can you automate predictions
every week right because
the users who don't care about the model
itself are really only interested in the
output of the model so can you automate
giving them a model every single week
the answer is yes of course
um with GitHub actions this is literally
the 20 line file that automates script
that automates the automates the F of
opportunity predictions and it uses the
description file that we just talked
about to run every night after every
game so that's
4 or 5 a.m on Monday Tuesday and Friday
from September to January
and then it installs our on the machine
the virtual machine installs the
packages from the dependencies that I
listed in my description and then it
runs a script and that's it that's all
you need to do
um so you're obviously there's a whole
bunch of magic that happens in the back
end here but from an end user
perspective as someone automating your
projects this is already this is you're
leaning on a bunch of work by the our
Liv actions team that is out there and
it's ready for you to use right and
GitHub actions is free if you've got
Public Work public projects there's no
action limits Man action minutes limits
that sounded weird anyways
the last question and the one I think
that more people need to know about is
where can I make predictions accessible
um so if you're we've already we're
already talking about GitHub so the
common uh approach is to just commit
things to your GitHub repository right
well there's three things there's three
common problems with that I'll list I'll
talk about them here file size limits
and efficient binary data storage and
commit history chaos we'll start with
file size limits
this is approximate but I think the
GitHub file size limits are something
like 75 megabytes per file and two
gigabytes per repo in today's modern age
that's basically nothing right so it's
very easy to go through this so if you
have a CSV for example you might think
okay well maybe what I should do is use
an RDS file or a parquet file to use
Arrow or whatever kind of small file
size I think my friend Seb you'd like to
use Qs same same idea they're all binary
files
so the problem with that is that version
control is incredibly bad at dealing
with binary files
an example of a repository that has a
daily automation that basically
overwrites an RDS file every single day
it's really tiny so I've annotated it
for you the actual data in this
repository is 60 megabytes in size and
then get since this and I think this is
over like the course of six months or a
year has automatically backed up six
gigabytes worth of data that I didn't
know about until I decided that I need
to clone it down and do something with
the code
so one and then once I cloned it down
you can't push it back to GitHub because
git has a limit of two gigabytes so
I actually like rage tweeted a whole
bunch of the stuff when I found this out
if you really if you're really Keen you
can go find it
so it's incredibly bad what's happening
is that get Version Control is literally
tracking versions right and what it does
it compares the differences and tries to
log the differences but binary files
have or is are entirely different every
time you write it so git naturally
stores a copy right and that's why git
is really bad at dealing with binary
files so even if you're into parquet and
you know the latest and greatest there
it's very quick especially when you pair
it with actions that you kill your repo
like this
lastly this is another problem if you're
committing to the same repo that your
code lives in you end up with like 6 000
commits now pop quiz which commit did I
change did I did I make a typo in and
automatically write to the wrong file
well it was like 422 commits ago how do
I revert to that right it's impossible
so commit history chaos
there's obviously better Solutions
here's some math Solutions
um there's get large file storage it
takes care of some of the large file
size problems but it also wrecks your
git repository it's impossible to
collaborate with
um it's really hard for users to work
with because your data isn't actually
stored on GitHub and files anymore
charted everywhere Amazon S3 buckets two
problems one they cost money again we're
talking about free especially in
sustainable projects and the other
problem is that
um it's stored away from your repository
so you have no idea what data is
available for that repository
um and so someone's got this bucket and
it's got things on it it's really hard
to work with visually for the novice
user someone who's not using accessing a
terminal in a program programming
perspective to understand what data is
there lastly people still use Dropbox
for this sort of problem but if that
also really difficult to work with but
now from the command line side how do
you get files back and forth from there
the real solution again pairing with the
GitHub theme GitHub releases
and GitHub releases is it's kind of a
lesser known thing but you can make a
new release and release it is stored
right next to your repo so if you kind
of go through this section beside your
repo there's releases you make a new
release
you upload files to the release and then
when you're ready you can update those
files as desired how is this different
from the other git GitHub data repos
well there's friendly file size limit so
each file they upload to a release is
understood to be bigger so the actual
limit for a file is like two gigabytes
and you can upload as many of these
files as you want
so that's much more generous than two
gigabytes in total and 75 megabytes you
version by choice so when you upload you
overwrite the file unless you make a new
release right and if you're ready to you
know archive that data you make a new
release upload to that new new
repository and you still have the old
version
he just commit history claim you're
manually uploading you're uploading
through an API data stays with your
project so if I'm interested in what
data is available within the universe
data package you go through the releases
you figure it out you can point and
click and download and best of all it's
free
both Republic and private repositories
of course R is wonderful and there's a
package for everything
the piggyback package which I started
working with and it's originally by Carl
I want to butcher this butcher
um
came up with three functions that
basically run that whole process first
is PB release create
um you up you create a new release PB
upload to upload a file to a specific
release PB download lets you download
all the files some of the files or just
one file from that release
so to recap
today I presented three tools for
project immortality talked about our
package infrastructure to help make
things easy to install and also to
communicate what you want people to do
with your work talk about GitHub action
so schedule and automate things and then
GitHub releases as an awesome and
wonderful way to store data
so with that
with those three tools under your belt
I'd like to leave you with one last
question
how can you help your projects help
others now and into the future
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]